[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
titus raconte-moi toutes les théories de
chez l'adulte est bien malade de fait
tous les métiers
j'ai même été importateur dogmatique du
grand lac à mon roman
quelle corvée quelques faits ces
maladies mentales proches et j'ai besoin
d'un peu d'air fois fut tu veux rendre
un petit service titus droit d'asile et
ses terres si le gruiec a besoin de
moins pour sa science des gymnastiques
je veux tu me rappeler c'est avec
plaisir dans la vie alors parfait c'est
parfait et bien va vite au gymnase le
grand yaka y est déjà maman le plaisir
d'entendre empire and gas gas
grand yaka non voilà leur remplacement
score pour la dynastie kim y est t'as vu
c'est pour moschino cheap ou alors tu y
es voici leur jeunesse de mon ami guy
cholot antre de la chine antique qui
fait maigrir puis voyons premièrement se
posait sur la bascule comme bien
aujourd'hui 201 qu'il vaut mieux rire 26
titus au moins 42 et des miettes si je
suis le plus gros et ses moines oubliés
puisque je suis le grand yaka et ensuite
dans un moment taper dans le ballon
vannes fraude dont ils sont restés près
et bien à l'oral ou titus ta poubelle le
ballon une fois ce respirer un deux
trois caps et plus forts se tissent plus
vite et j'avais espéré c'est bien ça me
fait du bien de se voir taper si fort et
si cette saison moi avoue kron gacko moi
je n'ai qu'à me suis trop fatigué titus
tu es là pour faire 6 exercice complexe
on comprend pourquoi montesquivais c'est
la corvette dans une hausse tout comme
on voit la fraise alors je continue ma
gym de 6 3e 20 40 attractions de débats
où papa les oeufs lait titus c'est
excellent les barres parallèles et qu'il
faut que je trouve un moyen de mon
époque de grâce à perdre 28
même si des deux pieds c'est une très
bonne exercices soumis 39 faut que je
trouve une idée pour nous sortir de
l'homme vous vous pas finir en soutenant
lors ge peu d'imagés multiples
à soulever les ultimes j'aime beaucoup
cet exercice les monstres long que ce
que je dois faire votre sens il faut
soulever le tir et d'obtenir le bras
tendu au dessus de la t6 très efficace
pour maigrir c'est très délicate
ça y est les midis vous allez voir la
foule retient on donne tout dans ma tête
est plus violente ou l'alter gros tombe
par terre ne peuvent être magnifique
cette magnifique
vous saurez que c'est très dangereux
pour vous grand yaka déchirure main et
ou quoi parce que cet énorme poids va
retomber sur nos pieds et crack
vous aurez pieds plats comme oscar ce
type qui s'était juré il faut protéger
mes pieds j'y ai pensé grand yaka vous
allez vous mettre ici et monte son le
tabouret et propres à titus je le dis
dieu
tenez vous bien voilà mon fils aurait
encore hier je vous dis que tu subis par
le foyer bien fait et très bien relève à
non
oh la la il était temps que j'arrête de
l'exercice
les deux amaigri de 4 kg ce grand gars
qu'amoureux répondre comme un mot
d'abord à la toile
et après après c'est une autre histoire